des visites auprès des acteurs de
terrain pendant ces trois jours à
trappes marlène schiappa a multiplié les
rencontres
la dernière en date vendredi 4 mai
auprès des jeunes de déclic théâtre une
séquence des changes autour des
inégalités femmes hommes avant de
montrer à la secrétaire d'état des
saynètes d'improvisation l'atelier a mis
fin officiellement à son cabinet
éphémère dans la ville 3 qu'est ce qu'on
ressort c'est que il ya une richesse à
la trappe
l'initiative est déconseillé d'aller à
trappes avec tous les clichés négatifs
qui peuvent être véhiculés sur la ville
au contraire moi je vois des gens qu'il
faut énormément de choses qui se bougent
qu'ils prennent des initiatives et qui
ont envie de les partager et d'échanger
tout ça c'est très très encourageant et
enthousiasme en visite dans le centre
d'information sur le droit des femmes et
des familles à la maison de la justice
et du droit
rencontre avec les entrepreneurs ou les
associations marlène schiappa a pu
prendre connaissance de plusieurs
initiatives locales porte et attrape une
démarche de terrain apprécié par les
élus du territoire qui ont accompagné la
ministre dans son déplacement
c'est une démarche positive d'une part
et et amicale au sens noble du terme
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extrêmement important qu'à des membres
du gouvernement vienne au sordide en est
que dans nos quartiers c'est toujours du
tout rassurant de voir comme ces visites
de terrain et on souhaite qu'ils aient
beaucoup plus de gens de terrain qu'ils
soient associés à l'élaboration des lois
de leur côté les militants de la france
insoumise dénonce un coup de
communication
ils se sont réunis vendredi soir devant
la mairie trappe pour faire passer un
message à la secrétaire d'état
à part ces rencontres quels sont les
organes
non qu'elle peut apporter donc on est
venu justement pour ça savoir voilà on
veut moins de blabla plus de moyens pour
l'égalité femmes hommes
marlène schiappa va profiter de son
expérience trappistes pour valoriser les
bonnes pratiques et nourrir l'action du
gouvernement le 22 mai prochain emmanuel
macron doit dresser sa feuille de route
de la politique de la ville pour les
quartiers dits prioritaires